a valorem player impersonated faze
clan's valorem manager
in order to trick his former teammates
into signing up for what they thought
was a golden opportunity to become
faze's academy team invalorent
they put in over a month of work into a
fake trial sometimes pulling 10 hour
days
of scrims and practice they turned down
legitimate offers
from other orgs thinking they were
getting the opportunity of a lifetime
to play for phase except there was no
team
there was no offer the whole thing
was a lie well guys i've done a lot of
these cheetah slash
scam videos recently on this channel and
like me
you might be feeling like you don't know
who to trust out there in the world
anymore well
you can trust us here at the school
esports make sure you subscribe to the
channel
that way you'll never miss a video just
like this one
it's that easy the story begins on may
21st of this year
when valorem player and coach t dog was
approached by one of his friends
a77 who was part of a team of aspiring
valor and pro players
they wanted to make it big the group had
skills and talent but they told tdog
that they wanted him to coach them
for a huge opportunity they had recently
been offered the huge opportunity was
that this
roster was secretly trialling to become
faze clan's minor league or
academy roster invalorant now there's no
fully built out academy system
in valorum yet of course but young talon
always needs to be developed
naturally tdog was interested i mean
this is faze clan as in well faze clan
becoming a part of this team could
propel an aspiring player or coach
to the very top of the scene but this
particular dream was
too good to be true now if you were in
their shoes
you might be asking for proof at this
point well the proof
was provided to them by one of the
players on the team
joseph silent oliver silence showed
t-dog something that had already
convinced the other players that this
was a real offer from
faze screenshots of dms between himself
and infamous faze clan's valorant
manager the screenshots were of direct
messages apparently from infamous which
explained that the org was looking for a
semi-established team to work with quote
behind the scenes
now i can't really get much further into
the video without pointing out what you
might have already guessed by now
that these dms were faked infamous
really is faze clan's valorem manager
but these messages absolutely did not
come from him
infamous had never spoken to silent
silent had
faked the initial conversation and then
continued to do so
in order to string his team along in the
screenshots the fake infamous went on to
explain that
silence should get back to him when he
has a team of five players that have
some experience under their belts
at which point he would spread the word
around faze clan's management to keep an
eye on them
right before we delve too far down the
rabbit hole here let's quickly talk
about the motive for this scam why would
silent do this
well in the fake dm silent talked about
one of his friends who was playing
semi-pro cs go in the mdl who
according to silent felt like he was
quote wasting his time
playing cs go and that he could make a
bigger impact in valorum for those of
you that don't know
the mdl or mountain dew league is a tier
2
cs go league it's not the absolute
pinnacle of the game but it's a big deal
for aspiring cs pros
the mdl player that silent was referring
to was
vic who'd been a long time friend of his
to put it simply
vic was kinda on the fence sure he was
enjoying his time in valorum but he
still had one foot in cs go now i spoke
to t-dog
and according to him silent didn't want
his talented friend to drop valorum
altogether and focus solely on cs go
valor it was just a side thing for vic
he didn't actually want to do it
but silent knew how good he was and what
he ended up saying
was i don't know if this is a word for
word quote but i remember reading what
he ended up saying was
he initially had no bad intentions with
this he just wanted some leverage
to get vic to come over to valor and
because he knew how good he would be
so it appears this whole scam was due to
silence fixation
with vic the star player who was
somewhat on the fence about
which game he wanted to pursue but
silent knew that without him
he wouldn't make it very far in valorum
at all
according to tdog this isn't the first
time that silent's friendship with vic
have taken on a bit of a creepy nature
when this game
originally came out silent would
impersonate vic
he would send vic's stats and esea
profile to people
on valorent trying to get them to play
with him in tournaments and all this
other stuff
uh just impersonating him saying that's
me because nobody's gonna nobody knows
right you know that vic didn't play
valor at the time
as far as they know you know it's just
it's just silence esea account with a
different name you know that's all he
has to say right
so we've got silent with this long time
fixation on vic we've got t-dog being
brought
in to coach the team and we've got
everyone being strung along by these
fake dms between
silent and fazer's valorem manager
infamous
and every time the team raised any sort
of suspicion silent would produce
another fake dm between him and
infamous silent told the fake infamous
which
again was also silent that his team are
unsure about whether to commit to the
grind and that they're worrying about
being [ __ ] over
the fake infamous then conveniently
encourages them to keep going
and even hints at a contract in the near
future
this would put their concerns to rest
for the time being and they would get
back to the grind
scrimming practicing reviewing they put
in some serious
hours to chase their goal uh we'd scrim
around
four hours each day which i would have
to schedule
that's what i have to do beforehand
usually while i'm streaming i kind of
have to do that at the same time
then after that i would go over the bod
of us scrimming
you know explaining what we did wrong
what we can do better what we need to
focus on
and then after that usually me and a77
or me and anybody left over
would voter view after that so again
we're talking like at least on my end
like i'd say probably you know close to
10 hours of investment
a day by this point tdog and the others
had gone
all in on this they had individually
received delayed or even rejected
offers from other ballerin teams vic had
stepped away from his cs go contract
they had put all their chips on this
opportunity
according to tdog silent had told them
that faze would offer
six to eight thousand dollars a month
per player
and 5 000 a month for a coach now even
though the players were going along with
all of this
these offers were still hypothetical
some of them just wanted to speak
to infamous directly before going any
further but every time they asked if
they could talk to him
silent would shut them down saying that
infamous wanted to
quote limit contact to just silent
unless it was urgent
he called himself the connection that's
what he that's what he titled himself
so everything that we heard about phase
and all that all the updates were
through him only
we wouldn't get it from anybody else
it'd be him and you know
now we know it because he'd have to
write up the messages himself another
fake dm
was provided in which infamous
apparently said that although
faze was still fixed on them becoming
their new academy team
they wanted more time to watch them
develop before signing them
tdog told me that he and the others
weren't just frustrated with silent
secrecy
he also wasn't playing well in game
either
like at all silent himself seemed to
know this and remember
according to t-dog he started all of
this to try and latch on to vick's
success
he then offered to bench himself in
order to give them
the best chance of getting the contract
just think about that
he offered to bench himself for a
contract
that he was faking but while he seemed
content to criticize himself
he wasn't prepared to take it from
anyone else when a77
raised concerns about silence
performance silent used another
fake dm from infamous to try and get him
removed from the team
so he writes up a fake dm from infamous
that night explaining how infamous
watch the vods a77 is toxic he's a
problem
he needs to go and and silent tried to
get him gone
that night it was crazy you know we end
up
we end up all getting in a call you know
trying to like i'm trying to calm
everybody down you know aiden's
you know freaking out a little bit you
know silent is just like explaining like
what's going on
aiden's saying like you have to stop
this man you know you can't just cut me
off the team like that
so not only was silence stringing
everyone along with this web of lies
he was trying to get those that opposed
him removed from the fake offer
altogether despite the craziness
reaching an absurd level the team
continued to grind
day in day out for two more weeks then
one morning
tdog woke up to a message from silence
saying that infamous
had heard there had been leaks that
there was talk of phase signing them
going around the community
and that this wasn't supposed to happen
the team was shocked because
they hadn't talked to anyone in the
community about this
it looked like their hard work was about
to come crashing down that they were
about to lose the opportunity of a
lifetime
silent had told them again to not
message infamous about this in case he
pulled the plug on the whole thing but
they had had
enough it was then that t-dog decided
to take things into his own hands we
decided together we're like listen we
just need to dm infamous right now
travis you're the one who has the
contact just go ahead and message him so
i was being very vague i was like hey
infamous
i'm coaching your uh project roster
right now this and that this and that
and he's like project what do you mean
by that and he's like
uh you know the one with silent on it
the you know i'm trying to be like vague
you know keep it nonchalant like i don't
know much
and he's like i'm not following along
you know could you could you specify
more and i'm like
no no this is this isn't happening right
you know i ended up and then i ended up
going full blatant i'm like yeah
silent told us about phase academy valor
he's been talking to you for weeks and
weeks months and months like
you know we're supposed to be talking to
you this weekend about you know the next
step he's like you have no idea what
you're talking about i was like wow
there it is the penny hadn't just
dropped it had smashed through the floor
some were shocked some were upset others
were
mad as hell it had all been a lie
now eventually tdog made a video on all
of this in which he says
that this whole leak thing from silent
may have been
an attempt by him to pull the plug on
the whole operation
perhaps he hoped his team would just
leave it and walk away with no more
questions
silent deleted his twitter he blocked
tdog and the other players and
kicked them from their discord server
silent then sent tdog a snapchat in
which he apologized for
everything he admitted that he did it to
keep vic from switching to valorum he
said that he knew faze would never pick
them up but that he hoped they'd find
another org if they just stuck together
i respect him for you know not running
away with his tail tucked you know
trying to hide
at least he did say something you know
it wasn't that good of an apology you
know
i don't think he could have made a good
apology in the situation he was in you
know i mean
um but but at least he said it you know
he he stated why he did it
he understands you know how bad it was
and how messed up it was
and i just hope that he learns from this
you know we can use this as a learning
experience
for ourselves himself and anyone
watching or listening
that again this is like a very real
thing and it
happens probably often despite the [ __ ]
show tdog says that they still got
something out of this
sure they're wiser about this kind of
thing now but they also
improved as players as coaches as a team
they still want to take their hard work
and get picked up by an
org one day but hey at least they didn't
spend thousands on a new computer or
move home for this opportunity it could
have been
a lot worse the real infamous tweeted
out in support of the victim
saying this silent kid is an absolute
creature
don't let him anywhere near anything
you're doing i feel
so bad for this team manipulated and
lied to for months by a guy pretending
to be me
just disgusting behavior guys a complete
sociopath as for silent himself tdog
said that apart from that apology
they've heard nothing else from him and
they aren't sure if they ever will
it's a shocking story but it's also a
pretty sad one it might be easy for
anyone
outside of this situation to say that
they would never fall prey
to something like this but put yourself
in their shoes
they had a dream and a friend who said
he knew how to get them there and i
would actually reassure him
i would say aiden like you know all the
stuff that you're talking about yeah
sure you know it makes sense obviously
it's sketchy that he's the only one
talking about it
you know that we haven't talked to
infamous yet but who would do this
how is this a possibility what does he
get out of faking that he's phased
you know what if this is fake you know
he's just his name's just gonna get you
know he's gonna get taken off the face
of the earth you know
when it comes to online you know he's
never gonna show himself again
and you know that that's that was the
thing that you know kept spinning in the
back of my head this can't be fake who
would fake this
right and again like i just still can't
believe that he uh you know he pulled
something like this off
it's crazy it's mental
it's actually i'll bench myself lads go
on
you're going without me good luck with
the fake contract i'm literally
fabricating in your dms
good luck best of luck i'll do the
honorable thing